hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast and our first keynote
presentation variant interpretation -
molecular diagnostics challenges and
knowledge gaps presented by dr. Robert
Nussbaum i'm susie valdez of lab routes
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're excited to bring you this
educational webinar is presented by lab
routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
here's how this presentation will work
today we want to hear from you questions
comments and even answers can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get to everyone but if not we'll make
sure to follow up with you by email you
can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of a slide window if
you cannot hear or see this presentation
clearly let us know by clicking the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button at the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process for obtaining your credit I'd
now like to introduce our keynote
speaker dr. Robert Nussbaum dr. Nussbaum
is currently the chief medical officer
of nvj a genetic information and
diagnostic company from 2006 to 2015 he
was the wholly Smith professor of
medicine at UC San Francisco chief of
the division of genomic medicine and
director of the genomic medicine
initiative at University California San
Francisco he came to us UCSF in 2006
from the division of intramural research
of the National Human Genome Research
Institute
he received his
training in medicine in the Harvard MIT
joint program in health technology his
internal medicine training at Barnes
Hospital Washington University and his
genetic training at Baylor College of
Medicine
he is board-certified in internal
medicine clinical genetics and clinical
molecular genetics he is the co-author
of over 200 peer-reviewed publications
on broad range of topics and basic
applied human genetics and as the
co-author with dr. Roderick mackenz and
Huntington Willard of the popular
textbook of human genetics Thompson and
Thompson genetics and medicine dr.
Nussbaum was one of the board American
Society of Human Genetics where he has
also served as president he was elected
to the National Academy of Medicine in
2004 and the American Academy of Arts
and Science in 2015
I'd now like to turn the presentation
over to you sir
not dr. nest Baum all guys thank you
very much it's a great pleasure to be
here this morning I'm going to talking
to you about integrating genetic testing
into mainstream medicine whole genome
and whole exome sequencing what is the
technology and why is it so
revolutionary does this technology solve
the problem of integrating genetics into
mainstream medicine what I'm going to be
showing you today is that this new
technology has made an enormous
difference in making it possible to
integrate genetics more formally into
mainstream medicine but there's still a
lot more to go
that is not just the technology of
sequencing this is an entire ecosystem
that needs to be brought into play in
order to make this happen before we had
next-generation sequencing how did we do
sequencing we essentially did one gene
at a time so for example you might start
with some DNA
and you'd have a gene of interest shown
in red here and you would look at these
fragments and then use polymerase chain
reaction to amplify the particular
sequence of interest shown here with the
red arrows you would then have a
essentially a test tube full of these
sequences they're amplified and then you
could take this amplified fragment of
DNA sequence it and compare it to what
we call the reference sequence of the
reference genome so what is the
reference genome whose genome is normal
well nobody's genome is normal there are
billions of different genomes on the
planet we therefore need a consensus
genome if you can compare an individual
sequence and the reference is really a
consensus of the most common sequence is
found in volunteers it is not currently
very ethnically balanced there are
certain areas geographical areas of the
world that are underrepresented in the
consensus and we're learning more and
more as we go along as to what kind of
variation is common and in essence
normal does not cause disease in many
other parts of the world but we have a
long way to go until we have a reference
sequence that is really a consensus of
the world's population so whole genome
analysis which is either whole genome
sequencing or whole exome sequencing
whole genome sequencing is what it says
he obtained the sequence of most of the
six billion base pairs of DNA in any
individual while whole exome sequencing
is containing the sequence of almost all
of the 2% of the genome that contains
the exons of the approximately 20,000 or
24,000 genes depend on how you want to
count them that encode proteins and that
is what's called the exome next
generation sequencing is also called
massively parallel sequencing and the
reason is because the most widely used
next-generation sequencing technology
provides a few hundred base pairs of
sequence for many millions of DNA
fragments enough to cover the whole
genome at an average of 40 to 60 times
over at the same time in parallel in a
single flow cell so
that allows you to do then is exactly
what it says which is in a parallel
manner sequence massively many many
fragments at the same time therefore
being able to generate billions of base
pairs of DNA which you can then line up
and examine for changes or differences
between the sequence of that individual
and the sequence of the consensus
so here's ideal whole genome sequencing
which is where I hope we'll be going
over the next few years but it's going
to take some technological advances to
make this happen so you start with DNA
and you've got a series of four of
fragments from the DNA that contains
some sequences of interest for example
in orange what I show you are the exons
of gene two and then brown the exons of
gene one so you take these fragments and
you carry out next-generation sequencing
so that you get a bunch of partially
overlapping sequences which you then
line up by base by matching the bases so
that they form a contiguous or contig
sequence and then you assemble that de
novo into some sort of contiguous
sequence that combines all of the
sequence in a linear fashion this would
be ideal unfortunately we can't really
do this very well and the reason is
because the sequencing runs are
relatively shorts are only about 200 to
300 base pairs currently for the most
widely used next-generation sequencing
platform there are others that will
generate much longer reads and there are
other technologies coming along that
will allow you to do much longer reads
and that I think will get us closer and
closer to ideal whole genome sequencing
but currently for most whole genome
sequencing because the reads are
relatively short you run into a problem
and the problem are repetitive DNA's
for example a Lu which contains about a
witch's that makes up about 11% of the
human genome here and line which makes
up about 20% of the Union genome they
are inserted throughout to the genome so
that
when you take a DNA and generate
fragments and do next-generation
sequencing you may line up the nearly or
actual identical sequence from repeats
that are located in many different parts
of the genome and therefore this is not
how true alignment you're mixing and
matching so what's on blue which are the
unique sequences that are next to the
repeated sequence these are actually not
contiguous in the genome they're they
could be from completely different
chromosomes and so it's very difficult
to assemble when you've got repetitive
DNA of this kind so instead through
actual whole genome sequence once again
one needs to rely on a consensus as a
scaffold upon which one applies the
sequence you generate so you carry out
next-generation sequencing and the brown
is the four-man gene one let's say exon
2 from gene 1 and arms is exon 3 from
gene - you generate the fragments the
way we talked about and then line them
up against the reference sequence and so
that you can form them into a conte and
the repetitive DNA is simply not looked
at in great detail if it is longer than
you can bridge in a sequencing run
sequencing fragment whole exome
sequencing is is similar except that
there's an additional biochemical step
there are a number of different ways to
do this biochemical step I'm just going
to show you one example so once again
you've got DNA
you've got fragments that contain let's
say fragments from exon one exon 2 and
exon 3 of a gene shown in brown pink and
orange what you then do is you have a
mixture of short synthetic DNA s
oligonucleotides that are complementary
we'll base pair to the exons of interest
shown up here and you attach these short
fragments of DNA to magnetic beads you
then mix these together
and you allow the short complementary
all of the nucleotides to kneel to the
base pair with the sequences of interest
and then you use a magnet to pull the
magnetic beads out containing the
fragments of interest and then you can
elute the fragments off from the beads
right here and now sequence them and
what you generate then are sequences of
the various different exons shown here
is the exon 3 and then align it once
again to the reference to form the to
the consensus so that you know that
you're looking at a particular region of
the genome by using the consensus as a
scaffold so that's the basic technology
that's currently in use but as I want to
just repeat that there are many ways
that people are attempting to improve
the next generation sequencing there are
different methodologies for sequencing
there are different ways of trying to
generate much longer reads in particular
reads though that will go across and
will bridge across some of the
repetitive DNA so that you can actually
do a de novo and now genomic alignment
or I should say a build up build because
you you will actually have unique
sequence anchoring you the fragments
that you are sequencing at the time in
any case we'll go on now to talk about
what are the four major steps that any
sequencing technology really needs to
meet our standards they need to meet if
the sequencing technology is going to be
used in clinical medicine and there's a
something called the ACE framework ACCE
which was created by the Centers for
Disease Control office of public
genomics this is from dr. new inquiry
and all of his colleagues there they've
done a very nice job of in a simple way
thinking through what are the basic
requirements for sequencing technology
to be successful in the clinical sphere
the first and this is true of course of
any test not just sequencing but I'm
going to be applying it specifically to
sequencing
the first is what we call analytic
validity can you get the right result
from the right patient this could be
anything from something as simple as
making sure that you haven't swapped
samples and you don't have a mislabeled
sample something very basic - something
much more technical which is if there is
a complicated variant a complicated
change in the DNA sequence is the
technology capable of detecting it
the second is clinical validity and that
is given that you can find what is the
variant in the genome what does it mean
does it have any association with or
does it increase the risk for there's
any disease does it have any health
implications at all and that is in some
ways when we talk about is the
penetrance in genetics which is given
that you have a particular genotype what
is the likelihood that it's going to
affect your health
what we call a phenotype the outward
manifestation phenotype outward
manifestation of an underlying genetic
alteration which is what we call the
genotype assuming we can interpret these
variants properly the next step is okay
oh how useful visit it to know that a
person carries these variants and do
they make a difference and if so make a
difference to whom and we'll talk about
that later and then finally is there
value to society beyond just the
individual in having test results and
why is that important what's important
for ethical reasons certainly to be
applying a technology which could have
important ethical ramifications in
society but there are also economic and
other social implications depending on
what country you're living in some of
these tests may be most of the tests may
actually be paid for by tax dollars or
by government funds in which case the
government really has a role to play in
deciding whether they wish to pay for
having these tests done so other
economic and then legal and social
reasons would these tests be used for
example in deciding whether people can
get health insurance or life insurance
would they be used in the workplace to
make decisions about whether someone can
cannot be employed these are all
important implications that have to be
considered when thinking of applying
sequencing to human beings let's talk
about analytic validity first what we're
really talking about here are true and
false positives did you do the right
test on the right patient and did you
find an abnormality when it's there and
not when it's not another way to think
about that is the term sensitivity and
specificity in people at risk or liver
disease how often is the test or the
sequence positive and specificity in
people at risk or without the disease
who are not at risk on or without the
disease how often is the test negative
sorry there's a misprint in the slide
should be people not at risk or without
the disease how often is the test
negative and that's the specificity now
in whole genome sequencing or whole
exome sequencing or panel sequencing
where you're looking at a number of
genes at the same time using
next-generation sequencing part of the
issue about sensitivity is a random
effect of coverage but coverage what I
mean is if you remember back to when I
showed you how to do this how the
sequencing is done you line up sequence
reads and then apply them to the
reference genome so that at any
particular base you can count how many
reads how many unique reads did you
actually generate from that person's
sample and that's called the coverage
per base how many independent reads
contain that base and so here's a curve
of what might be the distribution of
coverage per base where the the maximum
is around 350 or 400 fold around the
particular base and if you accept that
somewhere around 30x coverage is the
threshold below which you might not be
comfortable that you can actually call a
particular base accurately that you need
to see at least 30 if not more reads
containing that base in order to be
confident that you can read that base
properly you can see that if you have an
average of 350 or 400 coverage
that most of the time the vast majority
of the time there is no problem with
having more than 30x coverage you can
see even down here in the left hand tail
you're way above 30x coverage however if
your coverage is only averaging less
than a hundred X or maybe down around 60
X or 80 X then you have a problem
because part of this tail is actually
below 30 X perhaps somewhere between 2
and 3% and these numbers vary these are
not absolute numbers it depends a lot on
a number of technical factors but the
basic concept is that there are random
effects of coverage on your sensitivity
and your on your ability to read a base
at a particular location
there are also non random effects on
exon coverage so here's an example
here's a picture that I obtained
courtesy of dr. Sara Garcia where you
have shown in green and shown in blue of
the coverage per exon in the gene so
each each of these bars is an exon sir
Zechs on one right here is X on one and
here's X on two here's X on three okay
and what you can see is that in greeting
them in blue is the average depth of
coverage of per exon so you can see that
exon 1 there are close to 75 or even 80
coverage of that exon whereas for exon 2
it's a little lower it's more like about
40 and exon 3 the vast majority that
exon is oh yeah there are less than 10
to 15 reads per base and so that under
this circumstance exon 3 might be very
hard to read and why are there such
differences between different exons it's
because the coverage number of reads per
base is not just a random effect
there are also non random effects that
are based on the base composition of the
exon GC coverage GC content for example
also the type of sequence there if there
are runs of the same base it might be
difficult to capture because remember
when you're doing an exome you're you're
doing a biochemical step of pulling down
that approximately 2% of the sequence
that is contained in the exon so there
may be non-random effects as well in
terms of how well you capture particular
exons etc you can go in and deliberately
improve the coverage for basis for exons
that are poorly covered so what's shown
here for example is you modify the
chemistry or you modify the baits that
you're using so exon 3 now has been
boosted up to almost 30x by deliberately
going in and making a point of trying to
pull down more of exon 3 than before and
you can see that across the gene there
are marked improvements and yet still
even with the use of the extra baits
there are still exons that are not being
well covered shown each shown there and
there so so in addition to random and
non-random effects for analytic validity
for being able to detect what's there it
also depends on what kind of variants
single nucleotide variants or smv
there's a single change from one base to
the other are probably the easiest to
see if you've got the decent coverage
but there are some biases some
difficulties in being able to detect
variants other than snv's for example
copy number variants where you've got
large pieces of DNA perhaps few hundred
to a few thousand base pairs that will
simply be missing from the sequence and
because the sequence reads are so short
it's very difficult to know that they're
missing there are approaches to being
able to do this
I'll talk about in a minute but that
still represents a challenge so the kind
of very trying to find also has an
effect on analytic validity so for
example this is data from my colleague
colleague Stephen Lincoln
there are many pathogenic variants that
are quite technically challenging for
next-generation sequencing here's an
example we're not clear breast and
ovarian cancer cases well over a
thousand such patients and pathogenic
and likely pathogenic variants were
found in 260 out of them over 1000 and
here's the type of variants so only
about a third with single nucleotide
variants whereas the the small in those
which are short short repeats were a
little over sorry short insertions or
deletions of sequence where more than
half and what you've got is an even the
greater array of complicated variants
here 4.6% were multi exon deletion
duplications 3.8% were deletions and
duplications of a single exon within
these genes large insertions deletions
three and a half percent and then
complex rearrangements including
inversions 1.5 percent so snv's which
are the simple variants defined are only
about a third and pathogenic variants
are are particularly enriched for such
technically challenging such variants
and if you look across a genome and just
ask how many differences are there in
the genome between any individual and
consensus you'll find between three and
four million and they are by far the
most common difference however many of
them are common in the populations
many of them are benign whereas if one
is actually trying to find the variants
in a causing disease they have a higher
proportion of technically challenging
variants to find than just the total
variation between any individual and
the consensus so 13.4% are technically
challenging and here's some examples of
pathogenic disease-causing variants and
patients that one would call hard to
call by exon sequencing so for example
there's a a novel a Lou insertion a very
large in though this is involving well
over a hundred and twenty six bases
under lucid spaces that have been
deleted a splice site but unfortunately
this splice change is right next to a
run of 25 base pairs of home the polymer
just a twenty five days in a row and
next-generation sequencing has
difficulty detecting that a de t change
when it's sitting right next to runs of
a bunch of A's an inversion involving
exons one through seven a tandem
duplication in a five-prime CPG Allah
which is very CG rich as when its name
comes from or you could have pseudogenes
such as in the gene p.m. s2 which
involved in Rena teri colon cancer Lynch
syndrome where exons eleven through
fifteen are almost perfectly duplicated
within a pseudo gene that's located
elsewhere from the your gene it's not
the not the real gene itself it's a
pseudo gene and so that you may get
weeds from the pseudo gene section that
will be that will fool the software
that's trying to do the alignment and
you'll end up over calling mutations
that are actually not in the real gene
that are in the pseudo gene so the
prevalence out in other areas of genetic
disease not just in hereditary cancer so
it's about eight point one percent these
pathogenic deletion duplication events
they were seen in the little over one
percent of all the patients tested in
the in the lab where I work but seven
point eight percent of all patients with
any pathogenic variants and it varies
from from a clinic
areas so 8.1% hereditary cancer less in
cardiology much more in the neurology
because of major alterations that occur
in the charcot-marie-tooth PNP 22 gene
and in pediatric genetics in general
almost 70% so these difficult to see
variants are a challenge to analytic
validity and yet they are absolutely
essential that one be able to see them
if you're going to have good sensitivity
for detecting pathogenic variants in
patients who need a diagnosis now for
copy number variants although they may
be hard to see if you have sufficient
coverage and you control the lab
processes very carefully it is possible
to get a very good idea of whether it's
copy number variation between the
individual you're testing and the
consensus so here's an example of three
patients where what we've done is we've
mapped out the read depth the number of
sequences that are seen over exon 1 over
X on 2 and exon 3 and you can see that
it's really they're very tight they're
very close to each other the total
number of reads varies from somewhere
around 500 give or take 50 to a little
over 200 give or take for 20 or 50 and
here you can see that you're up around
an average of about 325 so these are
reasonably tight and that is in contrast
to this situation where you have a
patient who has a deletion in exons 1 &
2 and the actual number of reads seen is
reduced significantly in half you can
see that here here whereas exon 3 is
intact in this individual and so they
have the same number of reads as what's
seen in the controls you can
also do what we call split read analysis
where if the deleted region happens to
include two exons that are being looked
at for exon sequencing you may generate
a fragment here right here that contains
the junction between this exon this exon
with the deleted region missing between
them and this would be what we call
split read that you have a single read
that jumps from this X from the exon
here to the exon here within a single
read and allows you to infer that
there's been a deleted area between them
that's assuming of course that this is
all unique sequence and you're not being
confused by any repetitive DNA
so there are del dupe methods that are
powerful in when used in combination for
being able to detect larger deletion
duplication events so there are
limitations in the current
next-generation sequencing the
sequencing reads are reasonably short
200 250 maybe 300 the technology is
changing very rapidly don't hold me to
these numbers but this is the general
ballpark figure
NGS does not allow the novo construction
of individual sequence because of
repetitive DNA so you really have to
compare the unique part of each
individual sequence to a standard called
normal which is actually a reference or
consensus sequence de novo assembly of
contiguous sequence across repetitive
DNA sequences segments is difficult
repetitive DNA is a real challenge
including some very medically important
regions such as Triple E repeats in the
Huntington disease and direct detecting
deletions of duplications in this range
of 100 to 500 base pairs still
represents a challenge because of issues
and sampling and coverage
the next step now which is clinical
validity how do you know that what you
find means anything as quick community
is in a people who are positive for the
test is the disease present or is there
increased risk this is the opposite of
sensitivity which is in people in who
have the disease or have an increased
risk how often is the test positive
positive you value is the opposite the
people who are positive for the test how
often is disease present whose risk
number is this prediction and negative
predictive value isn't what medicine we
call the reroute and that isn't people
who are negative for the test how often
is the disease absent or is the risk not
any greater than that of the general
population now when you compare an
individual's whole genome sequence will
reference what do you find these are
ballpark numbers once again they're not
meant to be actually true for any one
individual but in general you see
approximately three and a half million
single nucleotide variants and about
half a million insertions and deletions
and if you go which ones are within
genes which ones are within the exons of
genes were down to 47,000 for single
nucleotide variants and almost 6,000
insertion deletions in exons and on down
so you can see that there's a lot of
variation in coding exons alone it could
just leave out the five prime to three
prime untranslated regions you still
have 20,000 signal nucleotide variants
and close to 500 insertions or deletions
but remember that insertions and
deletions are over represented as
pathogenic and so these are very very
important to detect but you still see a
lot and so the question is when you find
the variant how do you know that that
variant is actually involved in causing
disease because there's this background
of a large number of variants that
you're gonna find
anytime you sequence anybody so if
you're going to do variant
interpretation there are two steps one
is if you find a variant a gene is that
gene known to be involved in a
particularly disease not only when is
the gene disease relationship
if that gene is known to be involved is
there evidence that the variant the
particular change you found in that gene
is related to causing disease so for
gene gene disease relationship this is
this is an approach that's taken by the
clinton project which is a large nih
funded project in the united states
attempting to establish the lines of
evidence that would allow one to infer
that there is a relationship between
changes in a gene and a particular
disorder so inside you got here is
definitive evidence or strong evidence
and you need that if you're going to be
doing predictive testing or for
incidental findings where the patient
has no reason to think they might have a
change in that gene they actually don't
have a disorder that they're actually
fine trying to find out if they're at
risk for it or if you've stumbled on a
change in the gene while doing a test
for some other indication whereas if
you're doing a diagnostic panel less
stringent evidence is needed because the
patient is already demonstrating the
phenotype and then finally if you're
doing X on the genome where you're
actually trying not only to find
variants in genes you're actually trying
to discover new genes that were not
known before to be associated with a
particular disease they're more limited
evidence or disputed evidence can be
brought to bear in trying to infer that
a particular change is in a gene that
that gene in which the change occurs is
associated with the disease so a point
I'm trying to make here is that the
evidence you need to include a gene and
a clinical report depends on the context
depends on what the patient is
presenting with what sort of testing is
being done what the purpose of the test
is now in addition to gene disease
relationships once you find that a gene
is that the changes in a gene can be
associated with disease how do you know
whether any particular variant you
in that gene is actually associated and
the American College of medical genetics
with Association or pathology in the
United States just put together a
framework for five categories of variant
interpretation at the very top is that
one is quite certain that that variant
is responsible for the disease we call
that a pathogenic variant and at the
opposite extreme is variants that we are
quite certain have no impact on health
you're not cause disease we call those
benign in between our various levels so
we have will term likely pathogenic and
I'll tell you about that in a minute
what that means and likely benign
meaning we're not a hundred percent
certain or 99% plus certain that it is
benign or it's pathogenic but we're
leaning very heavily in that way and
then finally what's left is this
category in the middle which are called
variants of uncertain significance or V
us's where it's a change and we actually
don't know what it means it can be it
could end up being benign and in fact I
can't experiences most of the time they
do end up being benign somewhere around
80 to 90 percent of the time the us is
when they get reclassified and
reclassified as benign but not always
the case where is the meaning of likely
likely somewhere around 90% plus whereas
being pathogenic or being benign for
sure is more like 99 percent so this is
the framework that was put together it's
a complicated slide I want to go through
it all the way but I just want to point
out to use the following across the top
are the levels of evidence that one
would continue one will consider to be
either strong or supporting for benign
or levels of evidence that one is
considered to be either supporting
moderate strong are very strong for
being pathogenic okay and so for example
let's look at population data over here
if the minor allele frequency are and
they
is too high for the disorder or its
observed in controls and that's
inconsistent with the penetrance disease
in other words there are too many people
who have this variant who don't have the
disease and exactly how you measure too
many is something that we can would have
to discuss in more detail but that's the
basic idea it's just too common to be
responsible for disease since it's found
so often in people who don't have
disease at the opposite end if it's
found in affected individuals
statistically significantly more
frequently over controls then that would
be considered to be strong evidence for
being pathogenic so these are the types
of evidence that are used in this
process one has population data we have
computational data where you look at the
change itself and try to infer for
example a continent using conservation
is this an amino acid that Mother Nature
has conserved over hundreds of millions
of years or is it one that it's appears
that it can wobble a lot it can be a
number of different amino acids and it
doesn't matter functional data I have
people actually done experiments to show
that this variant affects the function
of an enzyme or changes the function of
a cell does it segregate in families as
a follow suit does the disease and does
the variant are they Co Co inherited do
they in other words segregate down
through a family is it found as a de
novo change there's a new mutation and
individual in the disease not present
neither unaffected parent etc so these
are the sorts of evidence and you try to
put together and using the databases of
various kinds and what do people say
about this variant has it been seen by a
number of different laboratories and has
it been seen by by researchers and how
do we collect that information and I'll
be talking about that in a minute that's
the kind of data and then you and then
you can assess how significant it is by
by assigning a strength from strong to
supporting for either being on the
benign side or being on the pathogenic
side and what you do is then add up how
many very strong or strong piece of
evidence you have what does it take to
consider a particular variant pathogenic
well what what you can see here is that
what it takes to be pathogenic is you
need one very strong and one strong are
two or more moderate or supporting
pieces of data or to Strong's
or one strong and and etc so I won't go
through all this but basically if you
cannot if you cannot place a variant
into any of these categories between
benign likely benign and up to
pathogenic then you're left with if the
criteria are met or there is discrepancy
that this piece of evidence to point you
one way and other piece of there
disappointing the other way then it's
called a variant of uncertain
significance we just don't know what it
means so one of the key issues is if you
apply this sort of information and
number of different laboratories apply
it what happens so this was an
interesting experiment and this is data
I got from dr. Gail Jarvik
I'm very grateful to her for sharing
this with me is from the clinical
sequencing exploratory research group
the seizure group where they did a
bake-off basically they gave 99 variants
to nine labs and they asked them to
classify them according to their own
internal lab methods but then also
adhere as strictly as possible to the
ACMG guidelines which I just showed you
and then what they looked at was both
intra laboratory within a laboratory and
inter laboratory differences in variant
classifications and the results were
really quite interesting along the
diagonal here was perfect match between
what people said using their own lab
information which is across the top lab
class and then what they would have
called it if they applied adhere to the
ACMG guidelines as strictly as possible
and you can see that there was a pretty
good
alignment 347 but there were still a
number of variants where there are
discrepancies off the diagonal so for
example two labs classified this as
pathogenic when they use their own
classification but when they applied the
ACMG classification those two variants
actually ended up being called the us's
so there it turned out that there was
79% identity but that means 21% of the
time there was a mismatch and some of
them quite significant so how does one
go about figuring out when variant
interpretations are discordant well one
of the tools has been developed is
essentially a very large crowdsourcing
effort called clinvar which is an nih
funded grant that has put together a
database where laboratories researchers
other expert groups can put in variants
and their interpretation and the
evidence for that interpretation and
clinvar has been somewhat controversial
I call it a hot topic there's good
there's bad and there's ugly sorts of
information floating around about the
value of clinvar and group here and in
vitae led by Steve Lincoln and Xianyang
and Scott topper a number of others have
tried to look at this question of when
is data concordant and when is it
discordant so for brca1 and 2 they did a
download of clinvar in May 2016 and what
they looked at was data that met the
following criteria and they tried to
make rather objective criteria for
example it had to be submitted by
established clinical labs it couldn't
just be a random researcher it had to be
labs that I put in at least 200
classifications in clinvar and they have
to be entries that were less than 5
years old because older we know and I'll
show you the minute older entries have a
tendency to be less consistent and it's
because we knew a lot less and for
example we were lacking one of the most
important tools that has become
available for very interpretation in the
last few years and that is a large
database of exome
called the ex act he xac from Dan
McArthur at the Broad Institute which
has been an extremely valuable database
that people use to try to get some idea
of what the normal allele frequency is
for any particular gram and they looked
at comparisons that would make a
difference in other words pathogenic and
likely pathogenic which are treated
clinically similarly we'll put in one
bucket and then benign likely benign in
the us's were put in another bucket so
this is what we would call clinically
actionable and the VOS likely benign and
benign is what you would call not
clinically actionable so we dichotomized
it into those two categories and looked
at a number of different laboratories in
the United States who had sufficient
data to be able to do this sort of
analysis and in general and you can see
here across the top is that there was
tremendous tremendous consensus or
concordance between different submitters
and there's really not a lot of very
significant dis corns but there was
something I mean for example we're
talking about discordance is down around
97% or 98% so that means that between 2
and 3% of these brca1 or 2 variant
interpretations were not totally
concordant across all of the
laboratories shown here so what's
responsible for this court so we took a
very deep dive into clinvar we looked at
all unique variants from all genes that
envita offers with at least two
classifications submitted by established
clinical laboratories including data
from the myriad genetics which was
submitted via something called the
sharing clinical reports project where
those variants were obtained from
coalition's who had ordered the tests
ended up being 38,000 total
classifications
14800 unique variants and an average of
about two and a half classifications per
variant from about 520 genes well you
can see here is that once again if you
dichotomize between pathogenic likely
pathogenic versus non clinically
actionable
the us likely benign benign and look at
different clinical areas shown in red
are the number of classifications in
that were found and the consensus shown
in red and blue and the consensus is in
the brown diamonds was a more than
two-thirds of the interpretations were
concordance so there could still have
been discordance E's but two-thirds or
more of the labs that submitted them I
had the same interpretation of
clinically actionable versus not and
shown in the blue diamonds here new
diamonds was 100% concordance there's no
no difference and it was a complete
agreement so you can see that in
cardiology the concordance rate was
dropped down to close to 92% for all to
agree so there was more discordance in
cardiology than the hereditary cancer in
the metabolic area the total number of
variants interpreted was actually quite
small so these numbers are less
dependable this is a very small number
but in cancer in ecology there were a
lot and if you look at pathogenic likely
pathogenic vs v OS vs. likely benign
benign so now instead of dichotomizing
you try condom eyes then the discordance
as you might imagine grew even more so
in cardiology for example to have
complete consensus that something is PR
LP versus v us versus LD or b we're down
around 75 or 77 percent what's the
source of these two scorns and why are
these discordance is there in Colmar
what we find is it really has to do with
who submitted the very interpretation if
you separate the variants interpretation
submitters into clinical testing
laboratories shown here in green
literature only or some sort of curation
and for example the online module
Aronson may
which has alleles listed as being
disease-causing although omen does not
interpret those variants they don't and
do their own independent verification
they simply report what's in the
literature in our databases that do
literature reports versus laboratories
that are doing research that submit you
can see that there's a significant
difference in very interpretation by
source with the concordance rates being
99.5 percent among clinical testing labs
and a draw drops if you use literature I
think what this is a reflection of is
that all the literature in particular
the requirements for being concordant
was actually quite a bit less the
requirements were not as stringent as
they are now and so older data daim that
was published in the literature that
that states that a certain variant is or
is not pathogenic is not as reliable as
current data so let's just in the last
few minutes talk about what is one of
the most difficult areas which is
clinical utility our test results useful
to patients well what do you mean by
clinical utility depending on who you
are like the blind men fueling an
elephant they all think it's something
different well different people think of
clinical utility differently the patient
says give me information I can use to
make life decisions that that I will
find personally helpful a provider will
want information that helps me diagnosis
prognosis or treatment what we call
clinical utility on the other hand
someone who is paying for this a payer
will say I only want to pay for
something that the provider is actually
going to use to change management and
then finally there may be a utilization
manager somebody who says you know I
don't believe in any of this stuff I
only want to pay for something that
improves an outcome preferably proven
through a randomized controlled trial
for which there is almost no such data
available for the vast majority of
genetic testing if for no other reason
most genetic disease is rare and putting
a randomized control trial for whether
testing is beneficial or not is simply
not very practical
so what we mean by clinical utility that
test provides information the patient
the clinician would like to know a
smaller subset is test result that
changes management and even smaller
subset is a test that provides
information improves outcome or saves
lives one very nice example I think of
what has been demonstrated as clinical
utility is is making a diagnosis and
ending the diagnostic Odyssey this is a
lovely paper from general American
Medical Association from the guca Baylor
College of Medicine we looked at 2,000
consecutive patients with for whole
exome sequencing because nobody knew
what was going on with undiagnosed
disease about a 25 percent had a
diagnosis made by whole exome sequencing
this shows you depending on what their
presentation was developmental delay
which is here or neurological plus other
things or just a neurological disorder
or no no non neurological read is the
number diagnosed believe is the total
and you can see that there's really a
substantial diagnostic you know 25
percent of time they could make a
diagnosis which was not able to be made
by any other method now the pay on the
diagnosis that then might lead to
management changes or might not but at
least from a diagnostic point of view is
obviously exomes have clinical utility
and what's interesting is 5% of these
patients actually had blended phenotype
that they actually had to single gene
disorders which together created a
disorder that no one could diagnose
because it didn't fit into either one
perfectly so whether something is
actionable enough is really in the eye
of the beholder there's a metric that
one can put together as to actionability
based on things like the severity what's
the nature of the threat to health how
likely is it that this variant is
actually going to result in this
disorder how effective is the
intervention that you're proposing in
other words to change the management the
nature of that intervention how risky
how burdensome how intensive is it and
what is the level of evidence that
supports this actionability so this is a
metric those put together by the Klingon
and I think it's a useful way to think
about trying to quantify and you can see
there are scores here of zero up to two
three as well as scores for the quality
of the data for figuring out whether
something how actionable something is so
is this actionable brca1 or brca2 this
is the a of making this diagnosis and
this is the risk of developing breast or
ovarian cancer with the arrows showing
you what the lifetime risk is in the
general population and so knowing the
year our risk for breast cancer that's
up your risk is upwards around sixty
percent or more if you carry a brca1
lifelong is likely to be an actionable
result and there are management
guidelines that will change the way you
deal with patients who have such
mutations offering them prophylactic
mastectomies and shall be more effective
music another way to think about
clinical actionability in this disorder
we have multi gene panel testing for red
eteri breast and ovarian cancer this was
a paper published in JAMA back in 2015
showing that patients who don't have
brca1 mutations and that that there was
an increased yield of such patients so
that if you only tested brca1 and 2 you
missed three point eight percent of
patients who had an actionable mutation
what end of those about half would get
additional disease specific screening or
prevention measures so one can interpret
that as a form of actionability
although I have to say that most of
these management changes are based on
expert consensus and are not based for
the most part on any kind of prospective
trial and so one could argue is this
really actionable if it's a bunch of
experts who simply say you ought to add
MRI scans for example through the breast
surveillance and can you actually
demonstrate that that has a benefit so
I'm going to finish up these are running
out of time here and I don't want to cut
off the discussion so
I think that I'm gonna end on this which
is what are the myths about using
genomics to personalize medicine so I
hope that I've showed you is that it is
not true that the technology is going to
solve all the problems there are issues
of clinical validity and clinical
utility that have to be dealt with no
matter how good the technology is I find
an attitude that genomics is really so
cool you don't need to gather the
effectiveness data needed for the
translation pathway I think this is not
true we people in the field love
genomics but there are people outside
the field need to be convinced in
particularly the people who hold the
purse strings that the patient and
providers of genomic testing do not get
to decide what's useful this is a myth
and the third-party payers and the
government's who support healthcare are
delighted to pay for it this is not the
case we have to make the case show the
evidence in order to convince the payers
to pay for it so I'm going to end on
this quote from Bill Gates we always
overestimate the change will occur in
the next two years and we underestimate
the change will occur in the next 10
don't let yourself be lulled into
inaction I think we have to make
tremendous progress in integrating
genetics through the use of genomics and
next-generation sequencing into medicine
we've got more to do we cannot just stop
here there's a lot more evidence we need
to gather and a lot more convincing we
need to do without I'm gonna thank you
very much ok
dr. Nussbaum thank you so much for that
informative presentation we want to
begin our Q&A segment so here's a
reminder as to how audience members can
communicate with us questions can be
submitted via the Q&A button at the
lower left if we are unable to get to
your questions due to time constraints
dr. Nussbaum will be answering submitted
questions via email we also would like
to ask you to take our two question poll
very simple it will be posted up on the
site as we're talking and we'd
appreciate you taking that so let's
begin our Q&A we have several questions
today one of our audience members would
like to know how does the clinical
utility of genetic testing work who does
it has a number of different or clinical
utility really has a number of different
origins I would say the lowest level is
when a group of experts get together and
say that laboratory result or that
sequence variant knowing that in this
patient is useful because we think it
should lead to some change in the way
this patient is managed the next level
above that would be that someone
actually does a some sort of a
retrospective look at a group of
patients some of whom had the testing
some of whom didn't and you could show
that if one had introduced if one
hypothetically had introduced some
difference in surveillance that one
could have had a better outcome for
those patients who had been tested
versus ones who didn't and ultimately
some sort of prospective followup with
patients it doesn't necessarily mean
randomized controlled trial that's
obviously the most powerful but some
sort of prospective showing if some
patients get a change in their
management and others do not based on a
genetic test result that one group of
patients does better than others and and
this that sort of level of information
has been has been
you can do you can hear control can
actually be historical in other words a
group of patients none of whom got
genetic testing and had a certain
outcome and now you're gonna look at a
bunch of patients who did get genetic
testing and you're going to change their
management based on what you see so this
is evidence development that has to be
done by the medical and scientific
community is not just going to happen
spontaneously we only have a couple
minutes left and we have one audience
member that would like to know WGS is
more functional towards diagnosis and
more expensive than WBS how do we use
effective molecular diagnosis and
continually expensive healthcare
management I'm very much of the opinion
of the opinion that that we need to
match the particular technology and the
cost of X technology versus the yield so
for example I can easy easily see
situations where we know that there are
let's say 250 particular genes that are
responsible for a particular condition
let's say childhood epilepsy to do a
panel of those 250 genes a full clinical
report costs a fraction of what would
cost to do a whole genome sequence and
do a clinical report on the sequence I
should mention don't be don't be fooled
that the only cost of a CEO of a test is
what it takes to run a sequence you also
have to analyze that sequence and give
us a full clinical report that adds
significantly to the cost so I think
some sort of staged approach where you
use a much less expensive test first and
see if it answers the question and if
not then in a in a fraction of patients
and whom you don't get an answer
the question move on to the more
expensive testing I think in our current
situation that makes sense I think in
the long run what's going to happen is
that whole genome sequencing will become
the standard for all genetic testing
when the cost of doing it and the cost
of analyzing it drops to the point that
makes it practical we're not there yet
but I could imagine that we could be in
in a few years so I think we're gonna
thank you sir we have time for one more
question and then we will have to close
this presentation what do you see as the
future of variant interpretation and if
you want to add any closing remarks that
would be fabulous if you're the future
of that interpretation is going to be
multi-faceted first just as we do more
and more sequencing and bring to bear
information about the patient's we being
sequenced and things like the big
project in the United Kingdom or the
personalized medicine project in the
United States we are going to be
connecting peoples health records and
their sequence much more closely and in
much larger numbers and this is going to
allow us to make better influences about
what different variants mean for health
I mean at this point we're really very
much at the at the at the early early
stages of this where we're looking at
changes in genes that have major effect
things that cause disorders that are
inherited according to the Mendelian
manner we're gonna have to expand to the
point where we can look at multiple
variations in multiple genes and how
that then affects health that's going to
take very large number of patients and
much much larger amounts of data so I
think the feature of very interpretation
is in large data collection and large
data assessment the other is I think
we're going to get better and better at
being able to make in silico
interpretations we're really at the
infancy of that as well
to be able to look at a sequence change
and because we know a lot about the
particular protein or that particular
gene we can make a very accurate or at
least contribute a very accurate piece
of information to very interpretation
and then thirdly as these databases of
variants that are linked to particular
disorders increase things like clinvar
it's there they are growing at leaps and
bound gives the hundreds of thousands of
variants that are in clinvar I would
expect it to grow into the millions and
that's going to provide a very also a
very powerful large data set when used
properly so I would say the future of
interpretation is going to be large
datasets better phenotype information
and better in silico assessment of
variation and their impact on proteins
thank you again for this fabulous
presentation dr. Nussbaum I'd like to
also take the time to thank lab roots
for making today's educational webcast
possible these webcast will be available
for on-demand through July 2017 keep an
eye out for an email from lab roots
alerting you when the webcast will be
available for replay we want to also
encourage you to forward the
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
next time goodbye